-These are two of our writers,
Amber and Jenny.
-I'm black.
-And I'm gay.
-And we're both women.
-And I'm not.
So, here's how this works.
I'll read the setups
for these jokes,
and Amber and Jenny
will read the punch line.
Here we go.
The cover of last week's
"New Yorker" magazine
features a drawing
of Martin Luther King Jr.
kneeling with Colin Kaepernick.
-Said white people,
"What a great drawing
of Denzel Washington and Drake!"
-According to a new report,
America's
three top-selling beers
are Bud Light, Coors Light,
and Miller Light.
-While lesbians prefer Busch.
-NBC News recently
published a list of 2017's
top moments of black excellence.
-"What's black excellence?"
said Ben Carson.
-Amber!
-Sorry. He didn't say,
"What's black excellence?"
He said, "[slurring] What's
black excellence?"
-Critics are predicting
that the Billie Jean King movie
"Battle of the Sexes"
will be nominated for an Oscar
for Best Picture.
-It's a hilarious comedy
about a man who thinks
he can beat a lesbian at sports.
-The upcoming CW show
"Black Lightning"
will feature a black superhero.
-A black superhero
is like a white superhero
except his car won't start.
-What's -- A black superhero?
What's his arch nemesis?
-Punctuality!
-Over $60,000 worth of vibrators
were stolen in London recently.
-$60,000 worth of vibrators,
or, as lesbians call it,
a good start.
-Jenny!
-Sorry.
$60,000 worth of vibrators,
also known as one vibrator.
-[ Laughs ]
-I don't get it.
-They're expensive.
-Oh. I didn't know that.
-I bet your wife knows.
-Oh.
There have been
some suspicious charges.
LeBron James recently wore
a pair of custom sneakers
embroidered
with the word "equality."
-"That's the wrong way
to protest,"
said white people
about everything.
-According to
a recent interview,
director Luca Guadagnino
hopes to make a sequel
to the gay coming-of-age film
"Call Me by Your Name."
-It'll be about lesbians,
and it'll be called,
"We're Both Named Brenda."
-Hey! Hey, Seth.
-What?
-Why don't you tell one?
-No.
I don't think I should.
-Oh, come on. Just one.
-I feel like I'll get in trouble
if I do it.
-Seth, come on! Do it!
-Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
According to a recent article,
Jughead
from the CW show "Riverdale"
is the new lesbian style icon,
replacing the old lesbian
style icon, Bob the Builder.
-How dare you?!
-What?!
You told me it would be okay!
-You should be
ashamed of yourself!
-Black women and lesbians
are liars!
♪♪♪♪
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night," everybody.